[Music]
i was born and raised in the chaotic
streets of mexico city
this is jorge kanyes an activist
he's standing at an intersection in
mexico city wearing a black mask and a
cape
i was an ordinary citizen until one day
i went
to a lucha libre match you know the
mexican wrestling
and i decided to get a mask a cape
and to be the pedestrian vigilante of
mexico city
he looks out onto a busy street filled
with traffic lots of honking and
swerving
people walk cautiously trying to get out
of the way of cars
the cars are very fast
there's people with disabilities
other people
even mothers and fathers with strollers
there are also cars parked on the
sidewalk so pedestrians have to venture
out into the dangerous streets
and that's when jorge emerges out of the
shadows
my mother tells me not to do this
because i can get in trouble but once i
put my mask and my cape
and i watch myself in the mirror
you know it's like telling to yourself
like i'm here to do justice and that's
my goal
and let's go out to the streets
and do it
i'm watching this video that jorge's
friend took of him
jorge takes a breath and then he jumps
onto the front of one of the illegally
parked cars
and then
he walks over it
we've been walking for thousands and
thousands of thousands of years and just
100 years ago we started to drive these
killer machines
you know
so something won't happen with with
history
so now we have to take back our streets
and send this message that the
pedestrian is on the top of the cars
jorge has actually become kind of a
local superhero for his activities
he goes by the name peatanito which
means little pedestrian
he wears a black and neon green costume
and patrols the streets helping people
on foot and on bikes
and then i have the cape
that my grandmother made
this is a cape that has
white and black stripes
just like a pedestrian crosswalk
he paints bike lanes on busy streets
and he circles potholes and broken
sidewalks so people don't trip on them
when he's done he adds a little pee like
a signature
then he leaps to his next mission
[Music]
it's like having two different
personalities of course
because yeah you feel different you feel
like an authority you feel like somebody
that has a mission in this life and and
it's going to spread a message to the
people in the streets
you know and then i go back home and
take off the mask on the cape and do my
normal work you know
i'm alana strauss and this is overheard
at national geographic a show where we
eavesdrop on the wild conversations we
have here at nachio and follow them to
the edges of our big weird beautiful
world
this week we try and answer a question
is a bike friendly world an impossible
fantasy or a reality just around the
corner
we'll meet an urban planner who tells us
how to accomplish that and it's not just
painting more bike lanes
and we'll hear why activists in mexico
and the netherlands are so passionate
about cycling that they'll go to great
lengths to capture the attention of
people in power
we
kidnapped
the city chief of government what
[Music]
more after this
all right let's get something straight
here
when we talk about biking in this
episode we're not talking about
recreation we're talking about bikes as
an alternative to cars a way for people
to get from point a to point b
there's good reason to make that switch
transportation is the leading cause of
greenhouse gas emissions in the u.s
and cars make up the biggest chunk of
that bikes on the other hand i mean
there's virtually no pollution
of almost no energy use and the energy
that's used is actually good for you
by energy that's good for you john
pucker means exercise
john is an urban planning professor
emeritus at rutgers university he
specializes in bikes and it's not always
so easy to get along without a car but
for for all the time i was at rutgers i
had no car i actually don't have a car
myself so oh
i love you i love you i love you
we're gonna get along very well alone
all right so if bikes are so great why
don't more people in north america bike
it comes down to safety
when surveyed more than half of
americans actually say they're
interested in biking but they think it's
too dangerous because of you know
cars
from 1981 to 2010
motor vehicle traffic was the leading
cause of death for people under 44 in
the us
john says there's an easy fix for this
and it's not just creating bike lanes
everywhere
it's creating what's called a bike
network that's a web of connected paths
that can take a traveler from any one
point in a city to another
it's made with things like greenways
which are off-road paths so cyclists
never have to worry about cars
they combine those
with protected bike lanes with these
physically separated lanes that have the
concrete barriers or bollards or
shrubbery of some sort dividing the
cyclists from the motor vehicles
so it sounds like what you're saying is
for a city to be bike friendly you don't
need every street to have bike lanes you
kind of just need
enough of a network that you can get
pretty much from anywhere to anywhere on
a bike
safely
that's exactly correct the key word is
connection so you don't want to have a
really state-of-the-art protected bike
lane here and a wonderful greenway over
there
but nothing in between
bike networks are actually part of this
larger transportation network buses
trains sidewalks they'll let people get
around without cars you bike to the
train station take a train to another
city then take the bus to your house
that kind of thing
activists like jorge often push for all
these things at once like last may jorge
attended a protest after a mexico city
subway train collapsed killing at least
26 people
[Applause]
massive crowds of cyclists and
pedestrians marched down a main
thoroughfare
there's so many of them that they can
only walk at a snail's pace
some of them carry white roses
they chant justice
these protesters were angry
they alleged corruption was going on
in another moment mourners gather in
front of the collapsed train lighting
candles around a memorial filled with
flowers
some play music
[Music]
mexico city is just one of many cities
that doesn't have the best bike
infrastructure
i live in chicago one of the best cities
for biking in the u.s but bike lanes are
still pretty few and far between here
protected bike lanes are even rarer
and the few greenways and protected bike
lanes that exist
they're often disconnected meaning i get
stuck biking through busy traffic
and yet bike infrastructure is
incredibly cheap to build it often just
takes a can of paint and some traffic
cones
so what's the hold up to understand how
countries like the us and mexico have
become so reliant on cars we have to go
back in time
it's important to realize that in the
united states
we were one of the very earliest
countries to be mass adopters of the
automobile so already in the 1910s 1920s
1930s we had much much higher levels of
car ownership than
other countries in the world
these cars created a powerful new group
the auto industry and they lobbied
washington very very strongly to oppose
any car restrictive measures the auto
industry got all kinds of pro car
legislation passed
money to build highways free parking in
the street policies that encourage
developers to build the suburbs and even
laws against people walking in the
street a place that had always been
pedestrian territory
these measures made it harder to get
around with any other kind of
transportation
other places in the world including
jorge's town mexico city
followed the us's lead
so how do you convince the city in a
car-centric country to make a bike
network
meet this woman my name is areli carreon
i'm 51 years old and i've been a bike
activist in mexico city since
1997
i am part of the
founder members of the busy tecus crew
which is the oldest going
bike lobby group in mexico city when
orelli grew up in mexico city the air
was heavy from all the car pollution
this was a big problem because her
sister had asthma and seeing people
having asthma attacks is terrifying and
they began to you know to turn blue
their lips and their fingertips and well
it's really scary to watch
and this was caused by pollution
her sister's asthma attacks were so
intense that they often had to rush her
to the emergency room so as irelia gets
older she became passionate about
finding a way to reduce air pollution
from cars
and she starts to see cycling as a
possible solution and then i thought why
do we have this instrument that is very
accessible on price that is easy
and healthy
and democratic
and fun
and why don't we have
a way of using it every day
so orelli became a cycling activist and
that meant a lot more than just going
for rides
literally we have tried it all from
going naked on the bicycles wait
tell me about that tell me about that
yep a nude bike ride through the city
this happens in other cities too and
it's a tactic to get people to pay
attention to cyclists
but o'reilly took it a step further she
dressed as a famous statue in mexico
city called the angel of independence
so i joined this ride i was disguised as
this monument that represents the city
uh all painted in gold naked it was like
body with body painting on on gold and
with my wings
she took off riding down the street with
about a hundred other activists
people really took notice it was like oh
the the the monument is riding a bike no
it was it was amusing for the people to
watch
at the time aurelie had been talking to
a guy on a biking message board
and she sent him a photo of herself as
this golden angel
he replied back saying she was beautiful
and that later on became
our love story and and and i got married
with him and and we have two boys and 13
years of happy marriage until this day
so they became this powerhouse cycling
couple
scott supported the family which gave
irelie time to get really into her
cycling full time
she got more ambitious and decided to
take the issues directly to the
politicians
the mexican government had been
promising more bike lanes but they were
stalling on their plans
like politicians were laughing at us in
our faces and saying oh no cycling will
never be a thing in mexico city that
thing that you do is impossible
so in 2011 she and her fellow bike
activists decided to paint their own
bike lane on the street
right in front of their congress
about 20 of them show up one day with
brushes
and they just started painting
then the police showed up
but the activists had a plan
the police came over and we're you know
like watching what we're doing
so the people that was in charge of
talking to them were like hey polly how
are you hey what's up
and hey what are you doing eh
no we're just paying here this something
for the politicians to pay attention to
what we do because we want to ride our
bikes ah
and you know and
and just chatting like that it's like oh
and we're we have some coffee and do you
care to join us and now you want some
from my list and someone oh well
no
so some of them said yes and
join the fun and you know chat around us
and just watch us
they also work directly with politicians
in one event the city's mayor at the
time marcelo abrard was riding with the
activists as part of a campaign to
promote cycling in the city they were
supposed to ride along a pre-arranged
route but at some point our guy that was
guiding the right just decided just you
know out of the blue that he would ride
in another
street
so we took another route and their
security was really upset and really you
know scared that we took off with the
chief of government
the chief on the other hand was having a
great time you know he never was upset
or anything he i guess he never actually
knew what happened afterwards
orelli says this accidental kidnapping
allowed them to talk with the mayor
one-on-one
and later she found that combining this
ground-level direct action with talking
to politicians it really paid off
mexico city started installing the bike
lanes that it promised
20 years ago there was nothing there was
not one meter of bike lanes and today we
have 270 kilometers
that's about 170 miles an hour hopes
that this could be the beginning of
mexico city becoming a bike mecca
and if you think that's a pipe dream
get ready
we're about to travel to a country
that's a cyclist's dream and they got
there with the help of their own
vigilantes
more after this
a city with more bikes than cars might
sound like a fantasy
but it's already happened
today the netherlands is known as the
biking capital of the world
dutch streets are filled with bikes they
roll through some of the smoothest and
most connected bike paths in the world
here's john poocher again people have
this image i think americans have an
image oh cycling is just paradise and
it's always been paradise in europe in
germany and the netherlands and denmark
wrong
not true
in the 60s and 70s the netherlands was
like the us dominated by cars
the dutch economy was booming after
world war ii and more and more people
started buying cars
more traffic meant more crashes
in 1972 more than 450 children died in
traffic accidents
from all european countries the
netherlands had the highest level of
children being killed in road accidents
that's mario landalana a mobility expert
and a cyclist from the netherlands
when she was a kid she'd hear about
these accidents
and we heard that this girl
was killed
in
in a car accident
just a couple of blocks away on a main
road where i have had been cycling
every now and then so
it was quite
intense
and another girl she was killed on a
road between two
villages and then it happened to a
newspaper reporter
his daughter was killed on a bike on her
way to school in a traffic accident and
a year later another daughter was nearly
killed
and he said we have to go and do
something about it so his newspaper
printed a front page editorial about the
traffic deaths titled stop the child
murder
a community of activists grew around
this movement they demanded safer
streets and better infrastructure for
cyclists and pedestrians
one such activist was tom crotifroy he's
a visual artist and urban planning
mobility expert from the netherlands
well back then the car was the king of
the road so the city was packed with
cars
cars were driving everywhere
so in the early 80s tom and some other
activists wanted a bike lane on this
particularly tricky one-way street
so at some point we
send a level to the municipality that
that if they wouldn't do it we would do
it
so one dark night tom and his fellow
cyclist friends snuck out onto the
street and started painting the lane
themselves
just as they were finishing up two
police cars rolled up
and they put us all in the car to take
us to the police station
but the police didn't seem too angry
well
they said we had fair done it very uh
nicely
it looked well at the police station
they said that yeah yeah yeah the police
held them in custody for a few hours and
let them go but the most funny part was
that one of the shopkeepers in that time
the next morning noticed the cycle lane
in front of his shop the shopkeeper got
mad because he thought the lane should
be a space for parking not bikes
and then this funny thing happened
so he started to remove our
lame
and then he was fined by the police by
doing illegal work on the street
the newspapers wrote about the lane for
a week
the city finally caved to public
pressure and decided to keep it the
municipality claimed that they had
wanted to do it themselves we then send
a bill to the municipality for having
done the job for them
tom and activists around the country got
what they wanted in those days the the
shopping streets were packed with cars
and now there's hardly any
so
nowadays there is no need to go
painting bicycle lanes in the night
because it has been done by the
municipalities
thanks to all these movements these days
the netherlands has more than 23 000
miles of bike paths
when you walk through a dutch city you
see streets filled with bikes not cars
and as for traffic deaths
tom says that in the mid 70s over 3000
people were dying in traffic accidents a
year
that was in a population of 12 million
so that was quite high and
now the number of fatalities each year
is
with a grown population which is now 18
million
we are now at about 500 a year
i heard people say that a bike
revolution like this could only happen
in the netherlands
but this can happen and is happening
around the world
london paris tel aviv beijing they're
all rolling out bike networks
and if you think the us will never get
there
again john pooker
and so here in the united states i find
so many people
who are are disappointed or they're
impatient um and they say oh it's never
going to work in the united states well
yeah we've just started the us has only
been building out bike lanes and other
bike infrastructure for the last 20
years or so
but we're ramping up big time
most cities are making it way easier to
bike around
new york los angeles portland and 50 or
60 other american cities are building
out their bike networks
in fact if you live in a city there's a
good chance this is happening near you
i notice new bike lanes popping up
around chicago all the time
it's the kind of thing that's invisible
until you start looking for it and then
you see it everywhere
[Music]
and so we're sort of at the beginning
stage of where europe was maybe five
decades ago and it's going to take us a
while to get really a broad spectrum of
society cycling or it could happen fast
like look at the spanish city of seville
the government there rolled out a whole
bike network in less than two years
now the city has over 50 miles of
protected bike lanes and cycling has
increased over 11 times
aurelie believes quick change like this
could happen in north america too
she says we're moving away from the car
century and into a new era a world that
isn't dominated by the fear of getting
hit with cars so
i'm happy to say that this other world
is existing already and it's coming
and
it's no point in resisting and denying
that it's happening and
it's not you know only for a woman's
sake or or for the earth's sake or for
the children's secrets everybody needs a
better
planet a better way of living
and we have to choose to do that and
it's one of the tools that is very cheap
and it's maybe in your
garage right now it's a bicycle so
go
use it
enjoy it
more after this
[Music]
there is so much ground we couldn't
cover in our episode if you want to dive
even deeper into the world of green
transportation subscribers can check out
our september issue of the magazine
which features stories about electric
cars and hydrogen powered planes
also if you're interested in keeping up
with bike enthusiasts in our episode you
can follow urban planner jorge kanyes on
twitter at payatonito
learn more about aurelie carrion's work
at busytecas.org
and finally you can read more of john
puker's research in his book cycling for
sustainable cities that's all in your
show notes
and if you like overheard please take a
minute to rate and review us it's a big
help
[Music]
overheard at national geographic is
produced by laura sim brian gutierrez
jacob pinter and me alana strauss
our senior editor is eli chen
our senior producer is carla wills
our executive producer of audio is
devara ardellon
our fact-checkers are robin palmer and
julie beer our copy editor is amy
kolczak
and hans del su composed our theme music
and also sound design and engineer this
episode
this podcast is a production of national
geographic partners
whitney johnson is the director of
visuals and immersive experiences
susan goldberg is national geographic's
editorial director
and i'm your host ilana strauss
thanks for listening and see y'all next
time
[Music]
you